hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to totally accurate battle
simulator now this is a game that has
been obviously incredibly requested
because everyone I don't know wanted me
to play it and wanted me to either rage
at it or laugh at it I'm not sure which
because I haven't seen it in action so
this is the first time that I'm playing
it and I'm already confused because it's
a play button and then there's a new
game button so I'm just gonna hit blue
level 1 I don't know what is means what
I don't know their names and also wow
this is loud but holy [ __ ] uh-oh what
did I do
Oh No oh that's not what I want oh this
is the battlefield oh ok so should I go
for expensive or should I go for not
expensive how about I have a tea money
so for barbarians stagger down not very
Oh what the hi
why is my mouse in here get the mouse
out of here what are you doing oh oh oh
oh that didn't work how does that
supposed to work
oh hang on I gotta change something here
ok that's better okay that would get
very dark I are back now okay so that
didn't work so does it just want me to
do peasants okay go get um boys even
though there's more of them than there
are you wow this depth of field doesn't
make a goddamn bit dick of sense Wow
what stop playing grab-ass and beat him
to death
alrighty then Oh works maybe I gotta
encircle him yeah nope that'll that'll
probably get him
that's not spread out the way that I
thought they wanted to be oh the arrows
pointing it the way they're gonna go I'm
an idiot
I mean everyone knew that already but
wow wow okay
damn damn damn damn luis holy [ __ ] you
beat the [ __ ] out of them oh I have 800
money 1 hwacha whoa ok so the arrows
pointing like that's the battlefield so
now I just need to put a bunch of boxers
around it to defend the watcher yeah
it's good probably oh jeez um's ok watch
him well it'd help if you goddamn hit
him you [ __ ] box the [ __ ] out of them go
get him Larry
go get him steel that didn't work at all
well we're [ __ ] the hwacha didn't do
watch how about this I do the hwacha way
in the back so hopefully you can
actually hit some things and then I
peasant it up okay so the peasants are
gonna get killed immediately which is
fine by me I don't I don't care
obviously I'm a I'm a very cruel
Overlord
man this depth of field doesn't make a
bit of sense
yah yah yah yah yah can't show they're
coming back up oh that's not good oh
that's not good at all oh oh oh no oh no
slap him slap him good steal their
weapons oh god he's just hey buddy how's
it going there
oh you look good buddy okay so maybe the
watch isn't the way to go about this how
about we have shields up front in a line
wait a minute I don't think those are
the shields I'm thinking about I thought
those are gonna be people with shields
might not be that Alright fricking I'm
just gonna have footmen right up their
ass
foot man no men of foot no men of feet
and then I don't know some peasants just
just just cuz I like the way this looks
that's the only reason I'm doing that
go get him buddies you fell down on your
own what's wrong with you
Oh God that done look good hello oh hi
friend this is stupid they got destroyed
fun men are worthless this is baloney oh
this is garbage
what a bag of dicks I fine
you want to be that way I can be bag of
dicks too alright this peasant squadron
alpha is peasant squadron a dildo this
peasant squadron Conowingo is peasant
squadron I ran out of names Oh max Oh
well [ __ ] fine all right no peasant
squadron ear that's that's not what
we're going for here and then archers in
the back really gonna give it to them
and then one shield here for some
[ __ ] reason there we go ah jeez oh it
is a guy with a shield
well you shouldn't shoot through your
own guys oh lordy oh it's a massacre why
don't they just fall over like goobers
yeah get em archers whoa-oh I think they
noticed you don't go towards them
oh god will you this fellow you your own
teammate shot you that's what happened
your Europe you're killed by your own
teammate oh it comes down to this
I know oh you sack of crap Phil huh
[ __ ] Phil okay fine we're gonna do
this again
that almost added if my guys hadn't been
shooting each other which was the fatal
flaw in my plan okay I'm gonna keep
these guys as far away from the battle
as possible and then distract them with
the Expendables here go get him go get
him shoot him [ __ ] fell over why I
can't stack them too close apparently
they'll just be idiots yeah yeah
murderer
I don't know why my screen shaking this
is my heart thumping so much about this
battle what are you doing with your
heads yeah we're gonna get you huh you
can't kill us we're too smart for you
man they're going after Bravo over here
they're totally ignoring charlie oh is
that squad Colonel lingo I can't
remember
Oh dudududud ears we're farmers you
birthday birthday no no oh dear ma oh
I'll get you
Wow I'm jebediah now dad will [ __ ] me
skip goddamn ticketless this game is
really ridiculous I will admit so can I
at least look at what they have No okay
we're gonna do a shield charge yeah
we're gonna do a shield charge get him
oh that's a lot of camps over there oh
good you're coming in swinging we're
coming in hiding cuz that's what we do
the best
aah bonk OH get rekt
oh that didn't Oh can you know Oh you're
exposing your sensitive flank oh you've
been erode wow this guy's pretty tough
get him get him get him boy yeah get him
with their own arrows oh [ __ ] your plan
didn't work did it
we got mo coming in from the side he's
the rogue element don't worry they love
it
he's distracting him over here Phil's
distracting him luke comes in for the
takedown oh [ __ ]
moves a wrecking machine okay well this
is going a lot of nowhere oh no they got
fell um OH oh no they got mo this is
Bill Oh Phil's running away like a [ __ ]
Phil goddamn it
just be a man or a woman I can't tell do
something
ah all right fine then the thing is they
got uh they got a lot of arrows so what
we need to do is we need to spread out a
lot so the farmers seem to be very
valuable so what we'll do is we'll
encircle them
and we're just gonna spread out way
willy-nilly no don't stand together I
don't care if you're married you get
dead to gather but apart that didn't
make any sense but I'm a military genius
here go for it
get him well that's spreading out didn't
exactly work the way that I'd hoped it
would you're gonna get you're gonna get
get him get him boys
damn yeah stab him yeah you can't box
your way out of this one while boxers
are way worse than farmers buy a lot huh
you killed their own guys get him
they're demoralized
they lost their friends oh well that's
not good yeah them gap yeah you
penetrated their defenses now by their
defenses I mean their soft underbelly
and you've stabbed their crotch Wow
I gotta admit I I went in I kept seeing
this game and it looked really dumb but
looks it kind of fun
ooh they gave me a lot of money how
about cannon crews Wow okay three cannon
crews coming right up no there we go
that looks good
go for it Wow why did why why did you
start out midair the diggity sense girl
fire there we go
well you didn't hit anybody good god
that one guy sure died ow you doingg you
aspects don't be sad ah you suck so oh
my god bye that didn't work I don't know
why but it didn't work so we're gonna
overwhelm them with farmers we got a
front line of farmers it's gonna come in
like a a hurricane of pain and then
we're gonna have shield men right up the
butt straight-up shield men making a
sturdy line of defense and then coming
in from way down town is gonna be the
the spear men
yeah they're there the other rogue
element in this one no one knows what
they're doing no and then one peasant
he's actually the king but don't tell
anybody he might die get him get him
boys um Oh actually look cool I like
that very cinematic Oh death wow that's
actually pretty cool
well this didn't seem to work but the
spearmen are gonna come up and close
this one out
Oh poke you in the booty oh no I'm
coming for you oh you can't stop me well
I'll getcha
oh they got googly eyes I didn't even
notice that I got a little googly eyes
uh no it was mad cuz he was going
towards the cemetery over there well
listen
stay honest well crotch stabbed for the
wit this is so stupid but I love it I
see why you guys wanted me to play this
alright considering we have no goddamn
idea what's what's ahead of us we're
just gonna spear minute well that's well
that's let me just clear some of the
chuff here we got that and then uh cata
bull I could watch it
I do love me a good watcher I gotta have
three watches oh my god oh I can't have
three Hulk a one catapult go get him oh
my god they got shields
oh it's devastation holy [ __ ] it was
awesome Oh God cannibal don't go towards
them what are you doing wow you hit
Larry you ass
what a that's not an effective strategy
Oh God huh head um God anything would be
better than this catapult its killed
more guys than they
oh [ __ ] you more my guys anyway ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] you Steve I'm gonna mercy
end that one I'm Anna mercy on that one
but the hwacha worked like holy crap the
hwacha really laid into them
okay so if I stack these up a little
closer it's gonna kill all of them right
and then just spearmen me let me
actually intelligently spread this out
that seems pretty intelligent if you ask
me I'm a pretty intelligent guy so I
know what I'm doing Wow oh they didn't
die okay nevermind I thought that was
working it was actually a pile of crap
China again muskets
maybe muskets can punch through we're
doing this Revolutionary War Styles
guerrilla fighting go I don't even need
the last money wow what is that oh well
any day now
well that seemed impressive but once
again you killed your own guys dang dang
Oh
if you guys could aim this would be
deadly Wow oh man that was a slaughter
they slaughtered them I'm trying to do
more muskets have lines like this like
this not not quite as stupid as that not
quite as dense this is the smaller size
but it's not about the size of it is
about what they do one glorious chariot
coming out the middle get them
ah what is that that's awesome
oh that's so good oh that's so good get
him get him
yeah oh my god I think you got killed by
your own dudes again but Wow don't shoot
each other don't shoot each other don't
shoot each other don't shoot each other
deeds geez don't shoot it no no get him
now would be good ah [ __ ] Oh
close to the edge out there okay that
chariot drive though that was awesome
okay we're gonna lose this but yeah okay
let me get something a little bit okay
but give that that chariot run that was
awesome so we're gonna do lines of
chariot cuz Wow
get some good Shrek yeah nice well Oh
what is you're still going holy [ __ ]
get up kill him dead murder their
families Wow okay that now is not good
oh [ __ ] okay I love this I love this
okay so why is Archer
why would Archer be better or equivalent
to a musket is the big question here
because a musket seems to be able well
that was all my money try this try this
one line up boys
line them up light em up any day yeah
good job waiting don't move forward no
no oh he was taken out I knew it was
gonna happen she sits Oh God nope
okay all right let's stop being dicks
about this what's a poacher a million
poachers sure that's what I call thee oh
oh it's the mini Archer oh that's not
gonna do dig okay so I need something
that can bash through their defenses so
what we need to do is we need to create
clusters of muskets okay this will work
this'll work oh no oh no no no no where
are you aiming
Oh No yeah okay you guys you guys were
the Expendables anyway so I guess you're
just gonna die then oh they're exposed
all the shields are down get them their
shields are down
get them don't get each other get them
don't charge into their blades get them
get um one there yeah yay
spreading out is an important military
tactic okay I'm gonna do one more level
and that's gonna be the end of this bud
I don't know this is kind of fun
it's really fun I like this a lot okay a
lot of money so we need ballista ooh
right up in the corners yeah to
ballistas right in the corn I don't know
what the enemy is but I know this is
gonna vex them unless the enemy's the
vex oh [ __ ] these guys are gonna be like
the the the the bait yeah that's the
word the bait okay so peasants over here
you're the expendable ones
prepare to die well they fell over what
are you what is this blister doing what
what Hey
they've got a lot of oh my god okay then
okay oh [ __ ] that are we went Wow
are you okay oh [ __ ] man
Jesus are you alright holy [ __ ] somehow
he's alright he just shrugged that
cannon right off well in it help if
you'd hit him
this guy is invincible man oh my god
nice dodge dude Wow you suck really bad
you're great at surviving and you killed
yourself
it just blew yourself up you dingus so
we're gonna do this even more
differently than before so it's gonna be
Expendables there then straight up the
middle of the shields with footmen or
spearmen right
yeah this is gonna get him there's gonna
get him it's gonna get him yeah your
stupid cannons floating in from outer
space why is my camp on that side and
aren't their camp on this side that
doesn't make any sense
get him well you could get the cannons
that'd be smart
yeah spread out zigzag you get him
whoa [ __ ] ah my grundle
yeah can you can you guys hurry up
yo skedaddle faster to the cannons
because it seems to be a problem oh whoa
you are lucky got man you are you are
brave you are brave sir you're frickin
brave is [ __ ] free where are you going
oh that guy he deserves to be but stab
him
nice nice can you guys not fail us
please
this isn't even on that cannon anymore
no god damn Larry hey wow wow oh jeez no
you're not gonna be able to finish this
god dammit
even though even the cinematic music is
bored wha we'll get him some day Papa
whoa get him it's gonna be good yeah
alright I'm done I'm done
alright so I'll finish up this level if
I play this game again so let me know if
you guys want to see it again in the
comments down below thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
No
fine no one aboard go Forge the weird
dangly room reading out of gayness what
is this bird flu six parrot elite ill
eagle good